[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24 la
corte suprema de eeuu anuló el fallo
histórico roe versus wade que en los
años 70 reconoció el aborto como un
derecho constitucional en ese país para
las organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos se trata de un
retroceso enorme en temas de derechos de
las mujeres y es que hasta hoy eeuu fue
un ejemplo y un referente para el resto
del mundo en derechos sexuales y
reproductivos vamos a conversar sobre
este tema pero antes repasemos en la
historia de la lucha por la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo en el país
se jacta de ser el país de la libertad
hace casi 50 años eeuu legalizó el
aborto en todo el país la histórica
decisión del tribunal supremo de 1973 lo
estableció como un derecho
constitucional hasta la viabilidad es
decir hasta el momento en que un feto
puede vivir fuera del útero que ahora se
considera alrededor de las 23 semanas de
gestación
pero el caso roe versus weight también
suscitó movimientos anti abortistas
liderados por grupos religiosos que se
fueron politizando en 1967 ronald reagan
fue uno de los primeros gobernadores del
país en legalizar el aborto en su estado
california pero para ganar las
elecciones presidenciales de 1980 reagan
decidió que necesitaba el voto
evangélico así que cambió su postura y
se declaró contrario al aborto
no debemos descansar y les prometí que
no descansaré hasta que una enmienda
sobre la vida humana forme parte de
nuestra constitución
desde entonces los republicanos se han
redoblado y el movimiento ha ganado
terreno quiere que el tribunal anule la
sentencia de robert sus week
bueno si ponemos otros dos o quizás tres
jueces eso sucederá y eso sucederá
automáticamente porque estoy poniendo
jueces pro-vida en la corte go live y
just son de kurt durante su mandato
donald trump pre modelo dramáticamente
la corte suprema los jueces
conservadores ahora son la mayoría con
los derechos reproductivos en peligro y
después de darlo por sentado durante
muchos años los estadounidenses a favor
del aborto se están reuniendo
es una lucha que nos va a llevar a todos
a ganar y estoy aquí para decir que no
vamos a retroceder
de acuerdo
el 61 por ciento de la población dice
que el aborto debe ser legal en la
mayoría de las circunstancias la
conversación sobre este fallo histórico
es con carmen cecilia martínez del
centro de derechos reproductivos carmen
bienvenida a ellas hoy y comencemos con
el contexto porque son los momentos
después de que se conociera la sentencia
los estados de kentucky luisiana y
dakota del sur prohibieron la
interrupción del embarazo activando
leyes que ya tenían aprobadas con
anterioridad
idaho tennessee y texas también
aprobaron de forma automática la
prohibición del aborto aunque sus
efectos no van a entrar en vigor hasta
dentro de unos 30 días son en total al
menos 26 gobernadores los que están
dispuestos a aprobar las restricciones
parciales o totales y ahí va mi pregunta
qué va a pasar en medio de esta ola
republicana
muchísimas gracias a la decisión que
tomó la corte suprema de justicia es una
decisión catastrófica un precedente que
la convierte al menos con esta
composición en una enemiga de los
derechos humanos de las mujeres de las
personas con capacidad de gestar
creo que la pregunta es es muy buena en
el sentido de que pues ahora mismo no
podemos ya confiar en la corte como está
compuesta hoy pero si hay ciertos pasos
que debemos entre la sociedad civil y
puesto el activismo especialmente poder
concretar como es por ejemplo la
oportunidad que tiene el congreso
norteamericano para aprobar el la ley de
salud por la protección de las mujeres o
mejor conocida ya como el women
protection
el wii mensaje de protección a otras
leyes que también están allí para
proteger los derechos reproductivos de
las mujeres de las personas que están
test es muy preocupante que cientos de
mujeres de personas de niñas de personas
con capacidad de estar de persona
gestantes van a tener que buscar este
servicio en otros estados y muchas de
ellas ni siquiera tienen un estado
colindante que permita o que vaya a
permitir la interrupción del embarazo
imagen y si ustedes despertarse en un
país en donde básicamente
hoy puedo tener un embarazo producto de
violación y no lo pueden permitir debido
a esta horrorosa
mire usted estamos hablando de las leyes
que deben aprobarse del acto que debe
aprobarse para proteger la salud de las
mujeres y pues también está en
entredicho una aprobación de un acto por
la primera infancia y pues como se diría
es que los republicanos no solamente han
bloqueado este derecho constitucional al
aborto que se estableció en 1973 sino
que también se están bloqueando el hecho
de que pueda haber más ayudas sociales a
las mujeres en condición de
vulnerabilidad y precisamente la primera
infancia entonces ni por un lado ni por
el otro
abre la puerta a más vulneración es esta
prohibición
o esta anulación del fallo de roe versus
waves
sin lugar a dudas y además porque se
tiene que tomar en cuenta que justamente
las personas o grupos que tienen más
problemas o barreras para acceder a la
interrupción del embarazo e incluso en
la actualidad son aquellas personas o
grupos que vienen
desde son menos favorecidos no entonces
por ejemplo la población migrante las
niñas las mujeres jóvenes la aquellas
que provienen más de la ruralidad que ya
enfrentan barreras para acceder a este
derecho
entonces por supuesto que la decisión
empeora mucho más este panorama e
incluso todo aquello que se está
discutiendo que va también en contra de
los derechos reproductivos y por eso
también es muy importante por ejemplo
que busquemos otras vías para que las
personas puedan acceder a esta derecho
entonces te hablamos por ejemplo de la
oportunidad que tiene el congreso pero
además hay otras vías en donde se puede
garantizar el servicio como aquellos que
por ejemplo de impulsar iniciativas para
que la normativa de salud
provea el servicio lo tenga como un
servicio que pueda ser obligatorio
dentro del sistema de salud que pero que
haya mucho más vídeo y auxilios
económicos para que las personas puedan
desplazarse a los estados
y por supuesto todo aquello que tiene
que ver con la disminución de las
brechas de desigualdad de toda la
población que históricamente ha sido
distinta los dos niños en próximos
solamente con las personas migrantes
sino de grupos étnicos y espacial claro
y carmen es que aquí siendo muy
respetuosos de las ideas y creencias a
las que cada persona tiene un derecho
innato en la discusión no se trata de
estar a favor o en contra del aborto la
discusión del aborto no solamente en
eeuu sino alrededor del mundo se trata
de que aquellas mujeres que piensan o
desean abortar ya han tomado esa
decisión esta no es una decisión que
será reversible
lo que sí causa la prohibición y está
demostrado por las investigaciones es un
aumento de muertes maternas un aumento
de fallecimientos o de secuelas
irreversibles para mujeres que
principalmente están en estados de
vulnerabilidad y que no tienen acceso a
un procedimiento que sea legal y que sea
digno más allá de quienes decidan o no
abortar y quisiera por favor que nos
hablara de esto y como como este fallo
pues violenta también ese deseo y esa
postura de las personas que están a
favor de la interrupción del embarazo
absolutamente y es que prohibir el
derecho a un servicio de salud
reproductiva que es esencial digamos las
últimas guías
actualizadas de este año de la
organización mundial de la salud lo
establecen claramente es un derecho es
un servicio que tiene que ser esencial
así tiene que ser concebido a los marcos
en salud de todos los estados
y de hecho la regulación por la vía
penal no es la vía idónea para regular
este servicio entonces ahora justamente
se ve mujeres se pueden ver
inmersas en un sistema de
criminalización por la cuenta de que ya
por ejemplo en los eeuu no es
un derecho constitucional como lo decía
la anterior sentencia y lo cierto es que
la autonomía reproductiva es lo más
importante que cualquier persona con
capacidad de estar puede necesitar una
interrupción del embarazo a lo largo de
su vida sea porque está en riesgo su
vida su salud
no es tal cual como usted lo menciona
una cuestión de que si estamos de
acuerdo no estamos de acuerdo es un
servicio de salud esencial que cualquier
persona con capacidad de gestar puede
necesitar a lo largo de su vida y pues
la verdad que se haya revertido esta
decisión pone en riesgo la vida y la
salud de miles y millones de personas en
los estados bueno los defensores del
aborto como derecho constitucional lo ha
dicho joe biden en repetidas
oportunidades durante las últimas
semanas se va a tener la idea de
respetar la intimidad y la privacidad de
las mujeres y le preguntó por qué
eliminar este derecho al aborto en eeuu
pone a las mujeres en riesgo en otros
aspectos de su vida privada pone en tela
de juicio por ejemplo el asunto de las
relaciones abusivas y de la violencia
doméstica
si tal cual es la decisión de
interrumpir el embarazo es una decisión
que para una persona es una decisión
digamos
que quisiéramos tomar no no es una
decisión que está
que de alguna forma nos resulte espacio
y tomar la decidimos con base en nuestra
autonomía en la vida privada y
justamente porque muchas veces como
usted menciona también estamos inmersas
en círculos de violencia incluyendo la
violencia de doméstica o cualquier forma
de violencia de género y de prohibir
este servicio que es esencial lo que
hace es perpetuar la violencia en
nuestra contra y por supuesto que
estemos entonces enfrentando la
posibilidad de llevar a término
embarazos que son forzados y los
embarazos forzados son es ya están
considerados como una grave violación de
derechos humanos que tienen aspectos
para toda la vida las maternidades
forzadas tienen efectos para toda la
vida esto lo podemos ver sobre todo en
la en américa latina donde no solamente
los índices de violencia sexual son de
los más altos en el mundo sino que
además es la única región en el mundo en
donde los embarazos en niñas menores de
14 años
bunning un incremento imagínense ustedes
que ninguna niña víctima de violencia
sexual puede interrumpir un embarazo
producto violación
y prohibir un servicio de salud esencial
perpetúa los círculos de violencia para
todas las personas con capacidades está
bien ya nos acercamos al cierre en muy
brevemente quisiera pedirle carmen que
me hablara sobre esta idea que es la que
mueve en los derechos de las mujeres y
es la lucha por elegir nuestro propio
destino y por elegir una vida libre de
violencias para su conclusión
sí yo creo que eso es de lo más
importante creo que colombia está a la
vanguardia en este momento justamente el
fallo de la corte constitucional que
hace más de un mes
régulo la interrupción del embarazo para
que podamos acceder sin ningún requisito
hasta la semana 24 es un gran ejemplo de
nuestra lucha de la autonomía
reproductiva y lo vamos a defender ahora
y siempre hemos hemos enfrentado reveses
en múltiples ocasiones y enfrentando
estos derechos reproductivos y hemos
logrado revertir lo creo que eso es lo
importante que también hay que pensar en
la actualidad y en tal escenario de eeuu
es en cómo vamos a lograr
que algún día se revierta esta decisión
y además después ya llegamos al final
muchísimas gracias carmen e iu a su
respuesta yo le agrego que mientras que
en eeuu se retroceden los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos américa latina
está siendo bandera de una lucha por la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
como derecho y bueno pues estaremos
atentos a cómo se desarrolla esta
noticia gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros y para ya definitivamente hacer
nuestro cierre simplemente el mensaje de
la maternidad debe ser desear y debe ser
informada gracias a ustedes y sigan con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]